さぁて皆さん
お久しぶりです。はじめ社長です。
というわけで、今日はですね。
まぁ一週間前ほどに皆さんから、
僕の新しい名前を
コメントでいただいたので、
まぁ本当に
まずはたくさんのコメントありがとうございます。
こう、すべて見たわけですよコメント
で、まぁ、その中から
選び抜いたコメントで
まぁ、今日は僕の名前を
決めようっていう動画です。
(拍手)
じゃあ行くから！
これはね…
不覚にも笑ってしまったわ。
僕、亀田興毅じゃないですから！
Kazuさんありがとうございます！
本名は…
そうですね…
ちょっと考えときます。
Kazuさんありがとうございます。
もう…
もう、なんて…
これもふつうに笑いましたね。
かんたってもう…
微妙にかんたに似てるね。
ありがとうございます。
悪くない。
エルシエル、悪くないけど…
多分違う。
パトリシア…
ダメです。
何かもやしって僕の体型とかですよね。
もやしっぽいですけど…
もやしっていう名前は嫌です。
もう完全にもう、僕をもやしとしか見ていないですね。
ありがとうございます。
もう、
もやし係長ってもう…
もうおかしいでしょう？
のっぽりん、僕のっぽりんっ…
ん～。まぁ、悪くないな。悪くない。
けどしない。
おかしいっしょ。
えっ。いやぁ、でもたまに寝癖ついてるけど…
寝癖ボン…「こんにちは！寝癖ボンバーです！」なんて…
言わないよ！
いやぁ、これももう…
こりゃ下ネタ…
ハハ(笑)…もう、ちょっと待って。
とんがりごぼうってもう馬鹿にしてんだろ!
雰囲気がウサギっぽくて、
手足が長くてタコみたいだから、うたこん。
ウサギっぽいっすか？
手足が長いからタコですか。
ウサギ…う、うたこん…
ダメです！
PDRさんの本当の名前だよ吉田フェニックスっ…
もう、おかしいでしょ？
地面ですよ！
いや、悪くないです。これも。
はじめ王子っしょ？
なんか、王子ってなんか、かっこいいけどぉ…
会社でいじめられそうな気がする
どっ、どう…
ダーク・サクリファイス(Dark Sacrifice)ってもう、暗黒の生け贄って意味ですよ。
こんにちは！暗黒の生け贄です。
これはもう、名前じゃなくてもう、番組名だね。番組名。
あぁ、マイメロ的な感じですか。
はじめろ…かわいらしいですね。
はじメロディー…
これもきっとマイメロディの…
僕そんなマイメロディに見えますか？
おねがいはじｍ…もう、もう僕完全にマイメロディっすね、もう。
はじメロディでいいかな？もう。
いや、おかしいでしょ？
レオパレスこの部屋のことだよ！
僕レオパレスじゃない！
それは違う。